Friday, January 2nd was a day like any
other for Nicholas Maduro. The president
of Venezuela posted on Telegram about
his productive meeting earlier that day
before retiring to bed at his compound
in Caracus.
By that same time on Saturday, he was
sitting in a Brooklyn prison. In those
fateful 24 hours, Maduro and his wife
were captured at home by a team of US
Army commandos, brought by helicopter to
the USS Euima, 100 miles off the coast,
transferred to New York via 757 from
Guantanamo Bay, and processed through
DEA headquarters before being taken to
the notorious Metropolitan Detention
Center. But before the world could
process the shock of what just happened,
attention quickly turned to Taiwan.
If the [music] US president could pick
up the phone, order special forces to
invade its smaller, weaker neighbor in
the cover of night, arrest [music] its
quote illegitimate leader for violating
US law, impose a naval blockade, and
quote run the country from afar. Many
wondered, well, why can't China do the
same [music] with its defiant neighbor,
Taiwan?
After all, judged on its own terms,
Operation Absolute Resolve was an
unequivocal tactical success. No
Americans were killed. Maduro was in US
custody within hours, and whatever
diplomatic consequences that followed
were inadequate to make it change
course. Did the United States just give
China the green light to invade Taiwan?
Well, we don't need to speculate how
each of these countries would answer
this question because they have.
Predictably, Beijing rejects the
comparison entirely. In its eyes, Taiwan
is legally part of China, making it an
internal affair, unburdened by
international law, unlike America's
invasion of a sovereign foreign nation.
Amusingly, Taiwan agrees, though
obviously for very different reasons.
One of its lawmakers summarized the
ruling party's position quite
succinctly, saying, "China is not the US
and Taiwan is not Venezuela."
Nor does Trump see any parallels. When
asked, he explained why Maduro's arrest
was justified and by implication, why he
believes a Chinese invasion of Taiwan is
not. Now, you're surely thinking one,
two, if not all three of these answers
are transparently self-serving nonsense.
But for our purposes here, let's set all
that aside. This video is not about the
morality or legality of Maduro's
capture. It's not even really about
whether there are objective parallels
between Taiwan and Venezuela. My
argument is that Xiinping's decision to
invade Taiwan will be based on his own
perception and his own internal logic,
right or wrong. Likewise, Trump's
decision to intervene will be based on
his. In other words, Maduro's capture
will have very little if any effect on
either the likelihood or timing of a
Chinese invasion.
On January 2nd, Beijing saw the US as a
self-interested and hypocritical bully,
using high-minded principles like
international law as thinly veiled
excuses to promote its own narrow
objectives.
And on January 3rd, it still believed
that. On the 2nd, Washington saw
Taiwanese self-governance as beneficial
to American interests, and nothing over
the next 24 hours changed its mind.
Beijing has no trouble denouncing
Maduro's capture just days after
conducting its own military drills
against Taiwan. Washington has no
trouble defending Taiwanese democracy
[music]
just days after capturing Maduro.
Sure, you might say politicians may
never be swayed by charges of hypocrisy,
but the rest of us are. It's clear that
much of the world does see parallels
between Taiwan and Venezuela.
After a Chinese attack, America would
ideally assemble as large a coalition as
possible, isolating Beijing with
sanctions. And the more public
perception is on America's side, the
easier that task would be. There's
certainly a kernel of truth here.
America is running dangerously low on
global credibility. But if there's one
thing that could instantly wipe the
slate clean, unite the democratic world,
and galvanize support for Taiwan, it's
[music] precisely a Chinese invasion of
Taiwan.
Nothing inspires a renewed sense of
moral certainty or civic solidarity
quite like an unprovoked attack. Just
ask George Bush on September 11th, 2001.
Feelings of justice aside, there's also
just cold, hard realism. The small
handful of countries whose assistance
would be most critical to repelling a
Chinese attack are also those that have
the most personally at stake thanks to
their sheer proximity.
Japan, for instance, is both by far the
most important non US partner and the
most likely to actually materialize in
the event of a war. Regardless of what
the Japanese public thinks of the United
States, its leaders have been very
clear. They consider an invasion of
Taiwan to be a quote existential [music]
threat. When the chips are down and
bullets are fired, few democracies would
side with China simply because they
dislike Americans.
Even those with the benefit of distance,
like Europe, would likely be shocked
into action. Russia's war in Ukraine may
be geographically closer, but a Chinese
invasion would ripple through nearly
every aspect of our lives. In December,
a group of experts was asked to assess
the likely outcomes of such a war. They
predicted quote highly probable
neartotal embargos with the world's
second largest economy leading [music]
to globally lifealtering economic costs.
The co era supply chain disruptions
would seem tame by comparison.
But ultimately, it's not clear how much
any of this will truly matter. Sanctions
are often righteous, sometimes useful,
but rarely decisive. [music]
We've seen that firsthand during
Russia's war with Ukraine.
Even if all of these assumptions are
wrong, even if Maduro's capture so
thoroughly and so permanently
disillusions the world that a Chinese
attack is met with shrugs or empty lip
service, it may not make much of a
difference.
What does matter now more than ever is
raw military power. Remember, [music]
we know for a fact that Beijing wants to
absorb Taiwan. It's been very clear
about this for the [music] last oh 75
years. And since it hasn't done what it
so desperately wants to do, it follows
that it can't. At least, and this is the
important part, [music] at an acceptable
cost.
Like any other ruler, she weighs risk
against reward, hoping to extract as
much as possible for the lowest cost. If
he could take Taiwan through nonviolent
coercion, he surely would. If not, which
seems increasingly likely as the mood in
Taiwan hardens against Beijing, [music]
he assesses the odds of successfully
taking it by force. Which means three
variables will largely determine if and
when China invades.
China's military capabilities, Taiwan's
military capabilities, and America's
willingness to intervene.
The United States [music] can only give
China quote permission to invade by
adjusting the latter two knobs.
Everything else is barely a footnote,
including, frankly, what the average
German or Italian or even American voter
thinks. After all, Beijing is certainly
not trying to win a global popularity
contest when it comes to Taiwan.
Domestic Chinese legitimacy is all that
matters.
Now, about that first variable,
we know she is aware of his own military
deficiencies because he's fired nearly
everyone. At China's 20th Party Congress
in 2022, there were six men aside from
Shei on the Central Military Commission,
its highest military authority. [music]
One by one, five of them have been
purged in the four years since. China's
most senior general, in fact, was placed
under investigation just weeks ago.
Needless to say, you don't typically
throw your army into disarray shortly
before launching the highest stakes war
in your nation's history. She is clearly
aware of and concerned about some
combination of corruption, disloyalty,
and/or incompetence within his ranks,
enough to risk projecting an
unflattering image of the PLA abroad.
We also know Beijing is aware of
Taiwan's growing capabilities.
President Ling Da recently announced a
doubling of defense spending from 2.4 to
5% of GDP by 2030. And not two months
ago, the Trump administration approved
11 billion worth of weapon sales, its
largest ever package.
The last variable, of course, is more
intangible and thus harder to measure.
The best evidence we have that she at
least suspects the US might defend
Taiwan is simply that he hasn't yet
invaded. Not during Obama or Biden or
Trump's tenure. With a population 60
times bigger and an economy 20 times
bigger, after all, there's no question
China could defeat Taiwan if it were
thrown to the wolves.
Perhaps the clearest and most immediate
triumph for China following Maduro's
capture has been its newfound rhetorical
ammunition. Chinese diplomats have been
working overtime since January,
portraying America as a reckless
hypocrite. The question, however, is how
effective Beijing will be in converting
the world's very real distrust of the
United States into something more
elusive. Active support for China. She
has placed his country [music] in a poor
position to capitalize on unease about
Washington. Rather than staking out some
new alternative global system, he's
often simply followed in America's
footsteps, ignoring international law
when convenient in the South China Sea,
breaching the Sino British Joint
Declaration in Hong Kong, and taking
America's post 911 xenophobia to new
heights in Shing Jang.
Now, some argue that while America may
not have given Beijing a green light, it
at least offered a template, a model to
emulate.
But if she did study Maduro's capture,
it wouldn't have been of much use. His
goal is to permanently annex and reshape
Taiwan top to bottom in its own
autocratic image. Operation Absolute
Resolve was a surgical extraction of two
people. A mission American forces are
uniquely qualified for. There's a
reason, after all, Trump kept its scope
so narrow, even leaving Maduro's vice
president in place. Occupying any
country is extremely costly and
extremely difficult. Whereas, this would
be only step one of a 100 for Beijing.
It would then have to suppress and
govern 23 million hostile subjects.
Few in Caracus shed tears for Maduro.
Polls, in fact, show a majority of Latin
Americans hold positive views about his
removal. 87% of Costa Ricans and 78% of
Chileans, for example. Anyone captured
by China, meanwhile, would instantly
become a historic martyr. Unlike
Maduro's government, the ruling party in
Taiwan and its long formal line of
succession have strong democratic
legitimacy, and the Taiwanese people
would surely put up a spirited fight.
Maduro's capture came, relatively
speaking, out of nowhere. Taiwan, on the
other hand, has been preparing for
exactly one war for its entire
existence. Venezuela's military was weak
with only about 20 to 30 aging combat
aircraft. Taiwan buys weapons from the
world's superpower.
Finally, a Chinese invasion would be a
tremendous logistical feat, especially
for a country that hasn't fought a
single war in 50 years, and across the
rough, storm-prone Taiwan Strait, no
less. Needless to say, an attack of this
scale wouldn't come as a surprise.
If there's any lesson to be learned from
Venezuela, it's that even the United
States military is often forced to
settle for pretty modest ambitions,
running Venezuela, as it were,
indirectly and from afar.
Now, on the flip side, others have
argued that Maduro's capture actually
delays China's plans, or at least
unsettles Beijing.
First, they say it dispelled the myth
that Trump is an isolationist concerned
only about what happens within America's
borders. Nor are his ambitions confined
to a narrow sphere of influence. As last
year's strikes in Iran demonstrate,
[music] Trump is willing to intervene
far outside North and South America.
Second, the operation success proves
that the US is far from a paper tiger.
Despite Chinese narratives of American
decline, it still wields tremendous
influence thousands of miles away. The
president picks up the phone and power
changes hands on the other side of the
planet. Finally, they argue it exposed
Chinese [music] weakness. After rising
to power in 1999, Hugo Chavez quickly
pivoted Venezuela away from the US orbit
and toward China, visiting Beijing more
than any other Latin American president.
More recently, in 2023, China upgraded
its relationship with Venezuela to an
all-weather strategic partnership,
making it second only to the core group
of Russia, Pakistan, and North Korea. At
the heart of this friendship was a
trade. Caracus needed cash, ideally with
no questions asked, and Beijing needed
crude. China bought north of 80% of
Venezuela's oil, and Venezuela in turn
used that money to buy Chinese weapons,
becoming its number one buyer in Latin
America. All that, of course, is now in
jeopardy. Not only did Beijing lose its
closest friend on the continent, the
argument goes, but its powerlessness was
laid bare for all to see. That telegram
post Maduro shared shortly before his
capture on January 2nd was about his
meeting with Chinese diplomats. In other
words, just hours after thanking his
all-weather friend Xiinping, Maduro
found himself handcuffed and blindfolded
on a US warship, [music] while Chinese
diplomats were left awkwardly wondering
if their next meeting was still on.
There's some truth to this argument, but
it too is wildly overstated.
For starters, it's true that China
bought 80% of Venezuela's oil. Yet,
Venezuelan oil accounted for a mere 4%
of China's oil imports.
Venezuelan oil is heavy and sour, not
the lighter kind it prefers from Russia
and Saudi Arabia. And because it was
sanctioned, it had to take a bizarre
two-month route to arrive in Asia. Its
only advantage was price. No one else
would dare buy it. It's still unclear
whether and how much of this oil the US
will let China keep buying. Trump
initially said yes, but [music] has
since earmarked all of it for American
refineries.
Still, even if these imports dry up
completely, Beijing will have [music] no
trouble making up for the 4% elsewhere.
And while Venezuela was indeed among
China's closest friends, some
perspective is probably in order.
Remember, Beijing isn't exactly the
world's prom queen. It doesn't really
have any close friends so much as it has
business partners. With only one or two
exceptions, the modern PRC has never
truly entangled its future with any
other country. Certainly not in any way
it couldn't quickly back out of when the
friendship stopped being profitable.
When Maduro's power slipped in 2015 and
19, for instance, China quickly and
quietly met with his westernleaning
opposition.
Likewise, China has never maintained the
capacity to intervene outside its
immediate periphery. Even during coups
abroad, Chinese citizens are often left
to fend for themselves while American
expats are [music] safely extracted. In
other words, while Maduro and she wore
friendship bracelets, the former never
expected China to swoop in guns blazing
to save him. Beijing doesn't have the
ability to do so, and it never claimed
to. One area where China actually does
have more to lose is [music] debt. Over
the past 25 years, Venezuela has
borrowed about $100 billion from China,
and about [music] 13 to 15 billion is
still outstanding. In a funny reversal
of the debt trap narrative China is
often accused of, it's now Beijing that
seems to be stuck in a debt trap of its
own. With Venezuela under Washington's
thumb, China may never see this money
again. 15 billion, of [music] course, is
not nothing. Still, it certainly won't
bankrupt the world's second largest
economy.
So, add all this up and what do you get?
Whether a net win or loss for China,
Maduro's capture is far from the
geopolitical Super Bowl. And don't take
my word for it. Full-time Taiwan
scholars like Ryan Hass have said as
much. quote, "Bijing is playing a
different game, and Venezuela is not a
huge piece of it. Following nearly every
geopolitical crisis, there's [music] a
sprint, particularly on social media, to
instantly make it about something else.
And Taiwan is very often that something
else. Before Venezuela, for example,
[music] there was the war in Ukraine,
which according to who you asked, was
either wonderful or terrible news for
Taiwan's future. We project our own
thinking onto Xihinping, assuming he
sees the world as we do, [music] when in
fact his perceptions of Taiwan were
shaped decades before Maduro's capture.
By taking a step back and observing
history unfold over a much longer time
horizon, we can hopefully gain a larger
perspective and see how misleading these
comparisons are. That's what I try to do
with these videos and also what I love
about oldest and newest places on Earth.
Joe Scott's new hour 40inute
documentary. I just watched it today as
I record this on Nebula, today's
sponsor, and its exclusive home. And
while it's not about Taiwan or China,
that's sort of what makes it a great
recommendation here. It's wonderfully
disconnected from the torrent of current
events we're constantly bombarded with,
making it the perfect escapist watch,
and even better, one you'll feel
inspired [music] and moved by. In short,
Joe set out to visit the geologically
oldest and youngest places on planet
Earth. You can imagine that brought him
to some pretty remote places. You watch
as he travels all the way to the Arctic
Circle in Canada's Northwest Territories
by float plane, then to Hawaii's Kilawea
volcano. It's way more interesting than
any documentary about rocks has any
[music] right to be. I learned a ton in
the process, and frankly, it's just
delightful watching Joe plan and
orchestrate such a massive project.
Nebula is home to dozens of other
amazing originals. Shows that make you
laugh out loud, like one of my personal
favorites, Amolish Everything, The Live
Comedy Debate Show. Shows that, if
you're like me, catch you up on all the
fascinating history you were never
taught in school. like Real Life Lore's
Modern Conflict series, which teaches
you about the origins of al-Qaeda and
the US invasion of Iraq and shows that
visually astonish and inspire you, like
Neo's Underexposure, featuring these
amazing 3D renders of things like the
Titanic. Nebula is adree and even gives
you guest passes so you can watch along
with your friends or family for no
additional cost. Now, normally Nebula
costs $6 a month, [music] but you can
get it for just half that by signing up
for a year with the link on screen or in
the description. Now, that's [music]
just $2.50 a month for all the originals
I mentioned and more. [music]
If you're not a fan of subscriptions,
you can also get $200 off Nebula
Lifetime with a lifetime link below.